dans un bar il est bourré archi bourré
mort il dit ouais vas-y je rentre chez
moi il fait de pas et pas fille ton par
terre il dit c'est pas possible je suis
pas mort à ce point je vais ramper au
moins jusqu'à dehors je vais prendre
l'air frais peut-être ça va me relancer
il rampe dehors il prend l'air frais il
se lève il marche de pas et paf il tombe
par terre encore et je suis mort à ce
point je vais je vais empêcher jusqu'à
chez moi heureusement il habite à 300
mètres tirant Piran Piran il prend sa
serrure il tombe il tourne il ouvre la
porte il me fait 2 m et paf il tombe
encore il dit mais j'ai qu'est-ce que
j'ai vu c'est pas possible il rampe il
montre les escaliers jusqu'à son lit il
se met dans son lit s'endort
d'épuisement de fatigue il a rampé trois
ça peut être comme ça il dort alors
demain sa femme elle dit gênant
tu étais encore bourré au bar hier
comment tu sais comment je sais il y a
pas trop du bar il vient d'appeler tu as
encore oublié ton fauteuil roulant
[Applaudissements]